your doctor may recommend an
arthroscopic rotator
cuff repair if the rotator cuff is
damaged the rotator cuff is made
up of four muscles and tendons that
hold the head of the upper
arm bone the humerus firmly within the
shoulder joint
the rotator cuff muscles pull
of inelastic tough tissue bands
called tendons in order to
lift and rotate the arm while
keeping the shoulder joint stable
a rotator cuff tear
makes movement of the arm
painful and limited or impossible
depending on the severity of the tear
in the  more serious injuries the tendon
tears from its fixed place in the head
of the humerus as the
blood supply to the tendons is poor
a rotator cuff tendon will not be
able to heal itself after
a complete tear and you will need
surgery your  rotator cuff may be
injured due to falling lifting
pulling  ar or making
repetitive overhead arm movements such
as throwing, swimming and painting
plus normal wear and tear that
accompanies aging can
weaken and tear tendons
your surgeon will start by making two
small cuts in your skin to gain
access to the inside  your shoulder then your
surgeon will insert an arthroscope this
device contains a flashlight and
camera and tiny surgical instruments
the arthroscope will project
images across the tv screen
to guide your surgeon's work your
surgeon will make a few additional small cuts
using small
tools to examine
your shoulder joint for
diseased tissue and repair the
torn tendon then your surgeon will make a couple
of holes in your
bone where implants
called anchor sutures will be placed the surgeon
will put sutures through the anchors
and attach them to the tendon  repaired
to reconnect the tendon  to the bone the
anchors and sutures will be
gradually absorbed into the healing tissues
at the end of the procedure your
surgeons will remove the
arthroscopic instruments and close your incisions
with stitches after the procedure the
shoulder will be placed in a sling
for support and protection you
will spend some  hours in the
recovery room and will most likely
go home the same day